if you're looking for bargains kabul's
charmand market is the place to be
from fridges to carpets all household
items are bought and sold here but this
market wasn't here a month ago this
trade began after tens of thousands of
people left the afghan capital when the
taliban took over
these days many others are selling what
they can to make ends meet
as jobs have dwindled the population of
kabul has increased tens of thousands of
people moved from their homes as the
taliban took territories across
afghanistan many are sheltering in
makeshift camps in the city
[Music]
the government of afghanistan is doing
everything it can to provide job
opportunities to afghans we call on
afghans to stay and not to migrate and
to help develop the country
although afghans have not seen this
level of peace and security in kabul for
decades people are still concerned about
the future
the government of afghanistan is doing
everything it can to provide job
opportunities to afghans we call on
afghans to stay and not to migrate and
to help develop the country
but there's a generational divide in the
opinions of women and sauda's mother
says she's happy there is no more
bloodshed and insecurity since the
taliban segregated people by gender she
believes the moral problems of youth
have been resolved
sauda and her mom came to the bank to
get some cash that's in short supply for
hundreds of these people who've been
coming to the bank every day the biggest
problem is the cash crunch every half
hour only a few of them are allowed
inside and when they go in they can
withdraw just about 200
every week most of the people here are
government employees or civil servants
who have not been paid for months
because of the cash shortage prices of
everyday items are rising and with
people's degrees purchasing power
businesses are suffering mohammed is a
business student who has learned to fix
mobile software to make ends meet
the queue at the bank extends to his
shop he's losing customers he needs to
pay his monthly rent of 700
like many afghans he's concerned about
the future but willing to give the
taliban a few years to see if the group
is sincere in its promises to make
people's lives better
maybe if the taliban government are
going well and they bring some facility
for our
pupils uh definitely i will stay here
western countries have frozen the afghan
central bank's assets until the taliban
delivers on its human rights pledges and
accused it banks will continue until
they unblock those billions of dollars
osama bin
kabul